hello everyone my name is christine
pascoe
and i'm the vp of sales and marketing
here at accelerated technology
laboratories
i've been working with lims and
laboratory automation for more than 25
years
and today i'm excited to share my
experience with you we're going to be
learning how we can leverage limbs to
achieve regulatory compliance
today we're going to be focusing on
three key learning objectives
the first is learning how key limbs
functionality
can be expanded with further automation
such as positive id or barcoding
next we're going to understand the key
requirements of iso 17025
which are those that are required for
cannabis laboratories
and iso stands for the international
standards organization
finally we're going to be gaining
insight into how automation
can actually help facilitate compliance
to the standard based on how the limbs
is configured
so now that we've defined our three key
learning objectives let's look at the
agenda
we're basically going to be talking
about three main areas the first
is limbs what is a limbs why would
anyone need one
why do people leverage excel and paper
versus automation what is automation
how can it be leveraged to reduce the
overall cost of the laboratory and
increased productivity and efficiency
and then finally what is regulatory
compliance and
how do limbs help to support that
the analytical cannabis laboratory plays
a very important role in ensuring high
quality finished product
and this begins from testing raw
materials
through production through finished
products so whether you're making
edibles or food and beverage products or
pharmaceutical products or skin
products testing is critical each step
of the way
in the next slide we'll learn a little
bit more about some of the things that
are tested for
in a cannabis testing laboratory
there are many laboratories that are
still using excel
to manage their testing results this is
something that
always surprises me because they spend
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
state-of-the-art instrumentation
for highly trained analysts for
maintenance contracts on the
instrumentation
and the final product which is what the
laboratory generates is placed into
an excel sheet and people always say
well you know it has a very low cost
well i would also argue that it has very
low functionality
and there's really no audit trail so if
you change your result there's no way of
knowing
when or if a result was changed and also
it is very easy to change data that just
because there is no audit trail
you can accidentally also delete data
data can easily be shared this excel
file can be emailed throughout the
laboratory or it can be placed on a
shared drive and different people can
access it
but what's often overlooked is that
there's much higher labor
cost because people have to interact
with so many different types of excel
templates that are set up
you know for different pathogens that
they're looking for or different
chemicals
or compounds and then also it's very
difficult to
keep track of the qaqc that's been done
and if any chemicals and reagents were
used in that testing
to make sure that you can link those
back to the testing that was done
using those consumables so that if
there's a recall on one of the products
that was used in the testing you'll know
which
test results were affected with excel
it's easy to make backups
but they're also easily corrupted and
i've talked to a number of labs that
have built in macros
into their excel files and when they
become
too full of data they become slow and
bloated so someone has to go and
manually archive data out of those
excel sheets and and finally
there's poor security it's very easy for
people to
to go in and modify data so these are
just a few of the reasons that you know
laboratories
like using excel but also many of the
challenges
oftentimes when people are using excel
they're also using
paper logbooks as well as microsoft word
for generating their reports
when we think of paper systems as we
just talked about we think of a lot of
interaction between the analyst chemist
microbiologist
with excel files typing in data
possibly from bend sheets into excel
templates and you have lots of room for
transcription errors and just the
interaction back and forth with these
excel sheets cost time if you talk about
a limbs it's really about
increasing productivity becoming more
efficient having a high data integrity
because you're eliminating transcription
errors
often times you've interfaced your
instrumentation so there's no copying
and pasting required
also it's about efficiency it's about
traceability
understanding what reagents and supplies
were used in the test that were
conducted
what qc was done on those tests and then
also
data sharing it's about data
accessibility increasing communication
across your organization
it's about leveraging automation such as
barcoding to rapidly
find samples in the system as well as
implementing barcodes for
label generation so when say samples
come in they can be quickly assessioned
and also it makes for much better
resource utilization
so you're using your staff your highly
trained chemist and microbiologist to
focus on the chemistry
and not pushing paper and cutting and
pasting
this slide depicts the entire solution
so basically you can have laboratories
that
implement barcoding to basically rapidly
assession
samples they can also leverage
dashboards so that
managers can have key performance
indicators at their fingertips
and then you also have a report designer
so that people without
ite experience can design simple reports
on their own
next there's sample scheduling so you
can
schedule shelf life studies stability
studies routine collections
followed by instrument integration this
has a very quick return on investment
and allows the data from
the runs to be automatically imported
and some instruments also
support the ability for the limbs to
send down the
run list to the instrument and then
after the samples have been analyzed
it can automatically send the
run list back to the limbs for import
and then finally clients can either
email
print or fax their reports to the
clients
with the addition of a client portal
customers can
check the status of their samples 24 7
they can also submit samples to the
laboratory as well as pay for them
and the nice thing about that is that
the laboratory will have the heads up in
knowing when samples will arrive because
the clients will have already pre-logged
them for
the laboratory and then clients can
check the status of their samples on
either a tablet or smartphone or a
laptop
so it really provides clients a way to
be more connected with their samples
and it also results in higher customer
satisfaction
so why are limbs critical they really
are the backbone
of a laboratory they not only keep track
of all the samples that have been
received
any quotes that have been sent out
invoice information
but they also keep track of the employee
training
their permissions within the system any
data that they've entered into the
system and there's also an audit trail
for any changes that were made
to the data at the end of the day
laboratories really generate
data that's their job they don't make
widgets
they don't provide um consulting
services
they generate data so it's really
important that that data is of the
highest integrity that's possible
and having it in a paper notebook where
it needs to be
you know transcribed to an excel sheet
there's a lot of room for error and
there's also a lot of interaction
between
analyst and paper we've worked with so
many clients that have got
away from their paper systems and it's
just amazing to me in the cost
savings not only in the maximization of
their resources
but the elimination of all the paper and
the cost to manage
and maintain and store that paper and
also um boeing
paperless really is good for the
environment in that it reduces the
carbon footprint so it's it's a good
option all around and also it
supports regulatory compliance because
you have an electronic record
of your results as well as audit trail
for any changes that were made to those
results
next let's talk a little bit about
positive id
positive id is bar coding it's rfid it's
any way that you are guaranteeing that
the sample is who do you say that sample
is
you can basically leverage barcodes with
um bench sheets and you can scan
in samples before you load up an
instrument you can also use barcodes for
sample disposition if you have samples
that are ready to be disposed of you can
scan them in and out
of a refrigerator an incubator
you can also leverage the barcode or
rfid for internal chain of custody so
you can track the movement of that
sample within the laboratory
and you can also use it to find any
sample within the lab
to track world real-time progress on
that sample
for laboratories that are dealing with
controlled substances there are a few
more steps to the internal chain of
custody
not only do they need to keep track of
how that sample was managed within the
laboratory but they also need to keep
track of
who handled the sample the quantity of
the sample the units
what tests were performed on the sample
the weight of the sample
how much was left after the test if any
was disposed
during the testing and then also
understanding where that
inventory is by location by the um
owner of that sample and also the time
it's spent in storage
and many elaborate many laboratories
actually leverage barcoding to scan
samples in and out of custody it's very
efficient and effective
one of the great tools that lims
provides that excel sheets don't
are dashboards they provide managers as
well as
analysts with information on the samples
that are going through the laboratory
so it's really having business
intelligence at your fingertips
they can easily view trends across their
operations
they can monitor in real time backlog
reports how many samples are waiting to
be analyzed
turnaround time reports what is the
average time it takes for a sample
to be analyzed from sample login through
sample disposition
what is the production look like how
many samples were analyzed
in the laboratory for a period of time
by analysts
what's the workload look like for
planning purposes
how many users were in the system how
much time did the user spend in the
system
and the nice thing about the dashboards
is they can be user configurable so each
user can have their own
set of dashboards that are meaningful to
them
next let's spend a few minutes on
discussing instrument integration and
how it works
it's actually very straightforward
instruments
put out data in a number of different
formats
csv comma separated value xls for excel
text or ascii xml there's a number of
different formats that they export
those formats are typically unique based
on the owner of the instrument because
even if 10 people have the exact same
instrument they can each set it up
differently
so that each instrument would require a
unique parser
to import that data into the limbs the
nice thing
is that once that data has been
electronically moved into the system
there's no need for any hand entry so
all that's required is review and
approval
clients can also take data from
subcontracting labs
and have them put that in a format that
they can create a parser for so that
that data can also be automatically
imported
now if we look at a number of benefits
of instrument integration
not only do they increase accuracy or
throughput but they allow laboratories
to do
more work with fewer resources and also
it avoids duplication in that you don't
have people having to copy and paste out
of excel
data they don't have to re-key in
results that came off an instrument
and the return on investment is very
quick it's typically 9 to 12 months
and that also enhances productivity
excuse me as well as
eliminating errors another advantage
that limbs provide
are the ability to view trends graph
data
eliminate outliers and then also the
potential to integrate with other
systems such as
jmp's sas statistical software
so that those that need to can do a very
sophisticated analysis of their data
and possibly view trends that they were
previously unaware of
another advantage is the ability to
automatically create reports once a
report template is created
that template is populated with the
validated and approved data from the
limbs
so that it can automatically be created
any signatures can automatically be
inserted that are linked to the user's
username and password
the report can be automatically pdf and
automatically emailed
to the data consumer and it can also be
linked to the
secure client portal for the end users
to access that report 24
7. so to quickly summarize some of the
benefits of a limbs
it's about generating the highest
quality data possible at an affordable
price
deploying standardization across the
organization
especially for laboratories or
operations that have multiple sites
it's about saving time working more
efficiently working smarter not harder
meeting the regulatory compliance
requirements
also it's about delivering quality data
rapidly to your clients
repeatedly that's secure
and then also working intelligently next
we're going to talk a little bit about
the regulatory compliance
aspect regulatory compliance
for cannabis testing laboratories
they're required to have iso 17025
certification this is probably the most
popular certification for analytical
testing laboratories
however there's other certifications as
well the states offer certification for
environmental testing laboratories
there's also needle act for
environmental testing laboratories
if you are organization that's also
managing
or manufacturing a food product then
there's also some food safety guidelines
that
are required to be adhered to so it
really depends on what the goal of your
laboratory is
but it's something that can easily be
determined with a quick literature
review to see which guidelines would
apply to your laboratory
why iso 17025 well it's a
international standards organization
accreditation and it proves basically
that the laboratory has an
acceptable quality management program in
place that's been audited by an
independent vendor
it also provides accurate testing and
calibration results
and that that laboratory performs tests
against standards and generates results
that are acceptable for different
regulatory bodies
so the iso standard for 17025 is divided
into three
segments or three major requirements
structural
resource and process and we're going to
go over those next
first we're going to cover structural
requirements and these requirements
refer to having a defined management and
organization structure so having an org
chart in place so everyone knows who's
responsible for what so
authorize people with necessary
resources
for executing their jobs and who has the
responsibility to ensure the
effectiveness of
not only the quality management system
but the laboratory activities
who monitors the performance and
identifies the deviations
and who's the person responsible for
taking action to achieve
improvement so there's continual
improvement in the laboratory
next is resource requirements resource
requirements
deals with people the personnel are
there mandatory procedures in place
for personal management how is training
tracked
this is laboratory training on specific
tests and methods
as well as safety training ethics
training
all the other training that each team
member goes through
and then also understanding the roles
that can be assigned to each team member
with their privileges and permissions
within the system so what they have the
ability
to do in the system what they have the
ability to see in the system
and then also peer review so if one
person
enters and validates a result a third or
second person will be
responsible for reviewing that result so
that's peer review when
you don't have the same person entering
validating and approving their own
result
additional resource requirements include
the facility
and environmental conditions so
basically
within a limbs one can manage different
facilities
one can also set up monitoring systems
that have automated alerts
where thermocouples are placed in
refrigerators freezers and incubators
and if temperature goes above a limit an
email can automatically be sent out
a text message can automatically be sent
and also you can have real-time updates
as to the the temperature of your
equipment and you can monitor it over
time as well
and then you can also generate reports
on the equipment and share that with the
metrology team
as required another aspect of resource
requirements includes equipment
management as well as metrological
traceability
so within a limbs users have the ability
not only to set up
and track pieces of instrumentation and
equipment
they can also keep track of the date
that that equipment was placed into
service the serial number
any calibration or maintenance that was
performed on that instrument
they can attach those documents they can
attach the user
manual and also within a limbs if the
calibration has expired on a piece of
equipment it can block
data from that instrument or piece of
equipment from going into the limbs
and it can do the same with employee
training records so there are a lot of
controls that are built in
and you can also look at trends for the
data to monitor the
performance of the equipment over time
you can attach documents as we
spoke of earlier in terms of the pdf
of the equipment user manual if there
were any
calibrations done proof of those
calibrations any maintenance or repairs
that were done on that instrument
so that you can go to one source and see
all the documentation also having it all
electronic
it eliminates the opportunity for it to
get lost or misplaced
and you can also document all the
materials that are used during your
calibration and maintenance
you can perform remote temperature
monitoring and that data can also be
stored
in the limbs probably not the every 15
seconds
of readings but maybe the average the
max and the min for the day
the final resource requirement we're
going to be discussing is externally
provided
products and services so with this we're
talking about reagents and supplies and
standards that are purchased by the
laboratory to be used in the testing
and the laboratory limbs actually has
the ability not only to just store the
specifications
of what's purchased but also to keep
track of the lot numbers the expiration
dates
the quantity purchased the price the
vendor so that if
you need to reorder you know exactly who
you received it from and then also if
you create any standards or reagents
internally you can also manage those by
entering in
the quantity produced the lot number the
expiration dates of the supplies that
went into that reagent
and then the limbs can be set up to look
at that expiration date
and not allow any data to be
imported from the limbs and if that
reagent has been used and
actually some systems will block the use
of that
reagent if it's reached the expiration
date so that the
end user doesn't need to look anything
up it's all done for them
and then also if a new reagent comes
into the laboratory
some labs will do their own testing to
verify that it meets their standards
before they release that to be used by
the rest of the laboratory and it works
the same way you can basically
put that into a hold until it passes
testing and then release it change the
expiration date
to the date that the chemicals and
reagents expire so that it can be used
by everyone
and then again not only does this
prevent expired
reagents and supplies from being used
but it also helps to ensure high data
quality
next we're going to wrap up with process
requirements
if we look at process requirements it's
a review of tests tenders and contracts
so basically when test requests are
entered the appropriate evidence can be
attached as necessary and this can
include
the chain of custody that the samples
came in with
any other documentation any
specifications that were sent to the
laboratory
can be linked to the customer and stored
electronically within the limbs
and then any new chain of custodies or
other reports can be generated
automatically from the limbs
so if a chain of custody is received
with the samples that can be linked to
the limbs
and if the laboratory is going to send
some of the samples out
to a subcontracting lab for analysis
they can generate a new chain of custody
to be sent with a sample
next is the selection verification and
validation of methods
all methods standard operating
procedures work instructions
pdfs of manuals can be uploaded and
linked within the system
version control can be applied if
there's any information on tester
calibration items they can be stored so
if a standard's received with a
certificate of analysis
that can be linked to that standard
within the system
and then the system is also able to
prevent a user from selecting an
instrument that's out of calibration
so in many systems if you go to the drop
down of available instruments if that
instrument's out of calibration
it won't appear on that drop down list
the next process requirement is deals
with non-conforming work or complaints
they're also referred to as kappa's
corrective and preventative actions
this functionality exists in limbs and
allows
laboratory users to basically document
deviations provide a description and
also
define the tester method or an inventory
item
they can basically determine the need to
take action they can classify the kappa
into a type 1 type 2 type 3 etc
then they can also document the actions
that were taken
and then they can carry out and document
the selected actions
as proof of the corrective process
and then they can also reassess the
success of their actions so this is
really the
entire uh corrective and preventative
action process so you have a problem
you identify the root cause and then you
put measures in place to prevent it from
happening again
the limb system can basically document
to an
auditor and provide proof that you've
done these steps in order and then it
also can document the time
that it took to close any open issues
who the responsible parties were
and what the final outcome was
another process requirement is technical
record traceability as it relates to the
audit trail
so basically if a result needs to be
altered
after it's been validated and approved
the system needs to make sure it
maintains the original result
the date and time stamps of the person
that entered the original result
as well as the units and after the
change has been made you need to keep
track
of the new result the date and time
stamps along with the
person that made the change along with
the reason that that result was changed
this allows an auditor to run an audit
report and they can see what changes
were made
in the system to final data and the
reason for that change
so it's very important to make sure you
have an audit trail
now another process requirement is data
integrity you want to ensure the
validity of the results
that are generated by your laboratory
one of the nice things about
instrument integration is it provides
the automatic transfer of data into the
limb so there's no
opportunity for transcription errors
also
the limb system allows users to set up
specifications or limits
for different tests and methods and also
matrices
so that if data is coming in from an
instrument and it breaks the limit it
automatically displays a color-coded
alert to the end user
so those alerts can allow the analyst to
take the appropriate action whether it's
spawning an automated email or a manual
email to a supervisor
qc results can be checked checked as
well um
they can the results can be trended to
make sure that the the result is valid
and if a retest is needed
a user can send the sample back for
retesting to
validate that result
next is reporting results in the limbs
each sample is assigned a unique
identifier that cannot be reused within
the system
results have different states from when
they're entered to when they're approved
privileges can be set to dictate who can
approve results so typically
one person will enter and validate a
result
and then a second person often a
supervisor will validate and approve
that result
results can also be audited we discussed
this earlier and reports can have
version control on them so that
a user will know a data consumer will
know if this is an original report
or an amended report and then also any
calculations within the system
can be verified validated and locked so
that they cannot be changed unless it's
by the lims administrator
the final result can be configured in
terms of if
any deletions were done on the sample
any decimal places are required or
significant figures so that result can
be configured for
reporting so oftentimes the raw result
or the measured result is not what's
seen on the report
finally validating the limbs the
customer and the vendor can work
together
or they can also hire a third party that
just focuses on validation
with i t support the systems must also
be protected against
unauthorized access it's very important
to have tight security so that only the
people that need to have access to the
system
are able to gain and access to the
system
and they also focus on maintaining data
integrity throughout the system and
that's doing database maintenance and
nightly backups if there are any system
failures they'll be automatically
documented
and the i.t department will have
processes in place to address any
failures so that the system's back
online
in many cases if there's a failure today
the end user isn't even aware of it
because everything's handled in the
background
and then also it's important that all
the user manuals are available they're
either online or they're in pdf format
some people prefer
hard copies and then also any
calculations and data transfers are
validated
if there's an api in place and data is
being transferred or web services that's
all been
verified and validated before it's put
into production
so to summarize this presentation it's
really important to select the right
limbs for cannabis testing laboratory
having the right tools for analysts to
do their job not only makes them more
effective and productive
but it also increases their efficiency
it helps
contribute to high data integrity to
high data quality
eliminating mundane tasks such as
copying and pasting or re-entering data
or having to manually record
temperatures leads to higher
job satisfaction it's really important
to give people the right tools to do
their job
and for laboratories it not only
increases productivity but it also
increases profitability
additional benefits of limbs include
having a system where you can increase
communication in your organization
so instead of tracking down the lab
manager to check the status of the
sample
you can actually log into the limbs and
check on the status yourself
and also limbs and laboratory automation
provide a quick return on investment
when you can automate a mundane task
it's not only more efficient more
effective
but it also leads to higher data quality
it also
facilitates regulatory compliance as
you've seen over the past few slides
everything from managing corrective and
preventative actions
being compliant with electronic
signatures having security with windows
authentication
and also having a comprehensive internal
chain of custody and audit trail on all
the results
it really allows laboratories to be
bulletproof for their audits
with that i'd like to thank every thank
you so much for your time today
if you would like to receive a copy of
this presentation or our free limbs
guide roadmap to limb success
please don't hesitate to email info
atlab.com
or call us at 800 565 limbs
5467 or visit us on the web at atlab.com
thanks again and have a great day